understanding the theory behind sales is  that you have a person who has  conviction and then you have another  person who has no conviction and  everyone knows that sales is a  transference of conviction right it's a  transference of belief and the bridge of  that is trust right and so the real  intention is that we must make sure that  A salesperson actually believes and  you'd be amazed at how many times they  don't really believe in the product yeah  and one of the things that is important  to understand is it's not a binary it's  not do my sales guys believe in my  product yeah it is how much do they  believe in my products